[Música]
más de 1000 civiles han muerto durante
la guerra en ucrania que ya completa un
mes en este tiempo rusia se apoderó de
la región de gerzón y ha destrozado casi
por completo las ciudades de jarquín y
mariupol pero los ucranianos resisten y
mantienen el control en kiev la capital
oxidante quiere unificar su postura ante
rusia por eso en una sola jornada hubo
cumbres de la otan el g7 y de la unión
europea en bruselas líderes acordaron
vigilar el oro del banco central ruso y
redoblar los militares en el flanco este
tendremos detalles desde la capital beca
el presidente de ucrania volodymyr se
les kit denunció que rusia está lanzando
bombas de fósforo blanco contra civiles
esta es un arma química prohibida en las
guerras aunque las autoridades
ucranianas muestran imágenes del
supuesto uso moscú niega las acusaciones
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
yo soy maría clara calle en un mes que
lleva la guerra en ucrania gerson es la
única ciudad importante que rusia ha
logrado controlar las tropas rusas han
destruido casi totalmente a jarquín la
segunda ciudad más importante y tienen
cercadas agudeza y mariupol los dos
principales puertos del país kiev la
capital sigue bajo el control de los
ucranianos pero la guerra ya deja al
menos mil 35 civiles muertos y más de
1.600 heridos según la onu además más de
10 millones de personas huyeron de sus
hogares de los cuales 36 millones
cruzaron las fronteras nuestras enviadas
especiales irene savio y leticia álvarez
nos muestran testimonios de las horas
posteriores al inicio de la invasión
[Música]
el 24 de febrero el mundo se paralizó
para millones de ucranianos tras meses
esperando una invasión rusa la guerra
había empezado
el catering aus a nova es una joven
informática que vio su vida quebrarse de
madrugada
cuando leí de las bombas al principio me
sentí frustrada frustration
no sabía qué hacer y pensé que no podía
irme a ninguna parte porque no tenía
sitio alguno al que ir al fatah no
puesto que toda su vida estaba en diez
sus hobbies amigos y planes de futuro
todas las copias son once años de mi
vida
pero tengo un hobby que es grabar vídeos
esto es algo que no podía dejar atrás
de cézanne ping con adler behind no es
la primera vez que caterina tiene que
huir en 2014 escapó de crimea desde
entonces convive con el miedo
tengo la sensación de que no importa
donde vaya rusia vendrá otra vez y
tendré que irme otra vez no siento que
exista un lugar seguro en ninguna parte
en ganar la historia se repite con
dimitros beats una alerta en el teléfono
y las llamadas de familiares en shock
alertaron a este joven abogado del ibi
me desperté a las 6 y en mi teléfono que
la guerra había empezado no me lo creía
pero recibí muchos mensajes de amigos y
familiares y vi los ataques en kiev
zhytomyr equipando franquicias en esta
parte intenté entenderlo pero no podía
ver esa noche durmió en su despacho
porque su apartamento está cerca del
aeropuerto
[Música]
las sirenas antiaéreas siguen retumbando
en cada recoveco de este país el drama
humanitario se suma a la destrucción que
provocan las bombas y la artillería
vidas congeladas y martirizadas por una
guerra
el presidente de estadounidense joe
biden viajará este viernes a una
localidad de polonia que queda cerca de
la frontera con ucrania allí se
informará sobre la situación humanitaria
el mandatario está en europa por las
cumbres de la otan el g7 y de la unión
europea que se realizaron el jueves
desde bruselas nuestra corresponsal
esther herrera nos cuenta cuáles fueron
las conclusiones de los tres encuentros
con los que occidente quiere unificar su
postura frente a rusia
día 2 reuniones maratonianas hoy aquí en
bruselas en que occidente se ha
conjurado para enviar un mensaje claro
de unidad frente a vladimir putin un
mensaje de unidad que se ha querido
escenificar especialmente en una cumbre
de líderes de la otan extraordinaria en
que se ha aprobado el despliegue de
nuevos batallones en todo el flanco
oriental de la alianza también se ha
pedido a la china que utilice su poder
de persuasión frente a moscú para que
haya un verdadero alta al fuego en
ucrania tras esta reunión los líderes
del g-7 también han aprobado nuevas
sanciones en concreto se va a prohibir
que rusia pueda hacer transacciones con
oro para evitar que sortee las sanciones
hasta ahora ya aplicadas recordemos
rusia sobre los países con las mayores
reservas de oro del mundo tras esta
reunión joe biden ha acudido aquí a este
edificio el consejo europeo para
reunirse con los líderes europeos en que
ha querido también enviar e incidir en
este mensaje de unidad pero sobre todo
en mantener las sanciones y también las
sanciones a la energía ahora mismo una
cuestión muy divisiva entre los países
de la unión europea a la unión europea
de hecho es muy dependiente del gas y
del petróleo ruso y algunos países no
tienen claro cómo poder aplicar un
embargo porque mientras países como los
bálticos y polonia están pidiendo que
haya un embargo lo antes posible otros
como por ejemplo alemania o hungría
insisten en que esto puede tener graves
consecuencias para los ciudadanos sin
embargo los líderes también han querido
incidir en la importancia de esta unidad
especialmente porque según fuentes
europeas esto podría provocar que rusia
de lo contrario gane otra de las
noticias de la otan es que el presidente
de ucrania volodymyr selenski intervino
en la cumbre ante la alianza y también
ante el g7 el mandatario acusó a rusia
de lanzar bombas de fósforo blanco
contra la población civil el kremlin lo
niega el arma química mencionada está
prohibida por el derecho internacional
pues genera profundas quemaduras que
llegan hasta los huesos y que pueden
reactivarse tras retirar las vendas
según human rightswatch veamos las
imágenes con las que ucrania afirma que
se usaron dichas bombas
esta fotografía tomada el martes en la
ciudad de irving al norte de ucrania
muestra una lluvia de estelas blancas
que iluminan el cielo nocturno para el
alcalde de la ciudad esta sería la
prueba de que rusia habría utilizado
municiones de fósforo blanco en la
ciudad una acusación lanzada nuevamente
en esta ocasión por parte de volodymyr
talansky
esta mañana hemos visto bombas de
fósforo bombas rusas de fósforo
fusión y ver si es que las autoridades
ucranianas aseguran que están
investigando el posible uso del fósforo
blanco por parte de rusia en irvine pero
también en la región del donbass vídeos
de aficionados tomados de hace dos
semanas parecen mostrar estelas de luz'
similares pero estas denuncias no han
sido verificadas de forma independiente
y moscú ha negado las acusaciones
es un arma incendiaria el uso del
fósforo blanco contra ciudadanos está
prohibido por la convención de ginebra y
si se demuestra su uso sería un crimen
de guerra
el fósforo blanco arde a temperatura
extremadamente altas hasta 1300 grados
centígrados por supuesto puede provocar
incendios pero también causar quemaduras
extremadamente graves e incluso mortales
expuesto a pesar de ser un arma
condenada en el mundo el fósforo blanco
se ha utilizado en varios conflictos del
pasado la guerra en ucrania también ha
golpeado al sistema de salud la
organización mundial de la salud
denunció que ha habido 62 ataques contra
estructuras sanitarias
además los suministros clínicos como el
oxígeno son cada vez más escasos
por eso médicos del mundo está
trabajando para abrir
logísticos y llevar medicamentos e
implementos desde rumanía hacia los
hospitales ucranianos desde la ciudad de
tchernitchin hablamos con jesús cruz
coordinador de médicos del mundo en la
emergencia de ucrania él nos explicó que
son los corredores y cuáles son las
necesidades una de las principales
necesidades que tiene a día de hoy la
población autam ya no esto del
suministro de bienes básicos para para
poder continuar lo que es la vida normal
dentro de estos bienes básicos está todo
el tema de las medicinas porque
en muchos hospitales se encuentran sin
medicinas y no pueden continuar la
atención médica lo que hacemos en primer
lugar es una evaluación de las
necesidades de los hospitales y en
función de estas necesidades pues
pedimos los medicamentos que son
necesarios estos medicamentos
o bien los compramos con proveedores
locales o los traemos mediante el
corredor humanitario que hemos
establecido y a partir de aquí a partir
de a partir de d
de ucrania hacia el interior por medio
de corredores seguros lo que hacemos es
importar todo de llevar todo ese
material la asamblea general de la onu
aprobó una resolución que le pide a
rusia que detenga la guerra en ucrania
de inmediato el borrador que propusieron
francia y méxico fue respaldado por 140
naciones mientras que 38 se abstuvieron
y 5 votaron en contra
estos fueron rusia y aliados como
belarús y siria no es el primer
documento que la onu afirma a prueba
para explorar el conflicto en ucrania el
2 de marzo el organismo ya había
aprobado una resolución similar y esto
no evitó que la guerra continua
gracias por estar con nosotros
[Música]